president Garibaldi Naro of Brazil prime
minister justin trudeau of Canada
president G of China president Emmanuel
macron of France Chancellor Angela
Merkel of Germany
Prime Minister Modi of India president
Widodo of Indonesia Prime Minister
Giuseppe Conte of Italy Prime Minister
Shinzo Abe II of Japan congratulations
to Japan are making a great decision
when the Olympics gonna make it next
year 2021 President Andres Manuel Lopez
Obrador of Mexico I want to thank the
President of Mexico for having done such
a great job with respect to the military
we have 27,000 Mexican soldiers on our
southern border and very few people are
getting through I can tell you that we
got to keep it that way and we have a
great relationship with Mexico now
President Putin of Russia King Salman of
Saudi Arabia president Ram posa
of South Africa president moon of as you
know a country that we spend a lot of
time in South Korea were working very
hard on that Prime Minister Sanchez of
Spain president Erdogan of Turkey
Prime Minister Boris Johnson of the
United Kingdom President of the European
Commission Ursula Van der Land President
of the European Council Charles McHale
United Nations secretary-general Antonio
Guterres World Health Organization
director Ted Rose
Edie han seong World Bank president
David Malpass and the International
Monetary Fund managing director
Kristalina Georgieva so that's a big
group but it's a great group it's and
they were all there every one of them
and we talked about the problem and
hopefully won't be a problem for too
much longer the United States is working
with our friends and partners around the
world to stop the spread of the virus
and coordinate our efforts we discussed
how vitally important it is for all of
our nations to immediately share
information and data and we've been
doing that to a large extent but we'll
do it even more so in to inform our I
guess you could say form each of us on
the fight that we've got going one way
the other it's a little bit different
but we're handling it a little bit in
different ways but there is great
uniformity I think we had a it was a
terrific meeting tremendous spirit among
all of those countries you had 20
countries plus the other people that I
mentioned and tremendous spirit to get
this over with
after the meeting with the world leaders
I spoke with the governors of our 50
states and territories our team has been
in constant communication with the
governor's and we had a we had a
terrific meeting somebody in the fake
news said that one of the governor said
oh we need Tom Brady yes again he meant
that in a positive way he said we need
Tom Brady we're gonna do great and he's
meant it very positively but they took
it differently they think Tom Brady
should be leading the effort that's only
fake news and I like Tom Brady spoke to
him the other day he's a great guy but I
wish the news could be could be real I
wish it could be honest I wish it
weren't corrupt but so much of it is
it's so sad to see just so sad to say we
had a great meeting I tell you what I'm
sure you have tapes of the meeting I'm
sure that you were able to get tapes or
easily see it 50 governors plus and if
you had tapes you'd see it was really I
mean there's no contention I would say
virtually none I would say maybe one
person that was a
tiny bit of a raising of a voice a
little wise wise guy a little bit but
he's usually a big wise guy not so much
anymore we saw to it that he wouldn't be
so much anymore but he is we had a I
mean I would rate Mike was there a lot
of the folks the back were there and it
was a it was a great meeting took place
at about 12 o'clock so we went from the
g20 to the governor's we also spoke
about the economic relief with the
governors and the package that we're
moving through Congress to deliver
much-needed financial assistance to
hardworking families and small
businesses
I want to thank Democrats and
Republicans in the Senate for
unanimously passing the largest
financial relief package in American
history 96 to zero and I have to say
it's the largest by far and I'm
profoundly grateful that both parties
came together to provide relief for
American workers and families in this
hour of need
the House of Representatives must now
pass this bill hopefully without delay I
think it's got tremendous support when
you're at 96 to nothing and as you know
a couple of those people are quarantined
and one Rand Paul as he's actually got
it
but he'll he'll be better said he's been
a great guy he's been a great friend of
mine actually the massive 2.2 trillion
dollar relief package includes job
retention loans for small businesses
with loan forgiveness available for
businesses that keep their workers on
the payroll it's pretty good loan
forgiveness keep the workers on the
payroll it's pretty good
direct cash payments will be available
to American citizens earning less than
ninety nine thousand dollars per year
$3,400 for the typical family of four
expanded unemployment benefits the
average worker who has lost his or her
job will receive 100% of their salary
for up to four full months these are
things that by the way we have plenty
more to go and but there are things that
nobody's ever had
any package like this then and I just
want to thank them hopefully it'll get
approved equally easily in the house
really I think it will go through pretty
well from what I hear virtually
everybody they could be one vote one
vote one grandstander maybe you might
have one grant stander and for that
we'll have to come back and take a
little more time but it'll pass it'll
just take a little longer but let's see
whether or not we have a grandstander
critical support for the hardest-hit
industries with a ban on corporate stock
buybacks and tough new safeguards to
prevent executive compensation abuse
over 100 billion dollars for our amazing
doctors nurses and hospitals forty five
billion dollars for the disaster relief
fund more than doubling the amount
available
this is tremendous stuff twenty seven
billion dollars for the coronavirus
response including sixteen billion
dollars to build up the strategic
national stockpile with critical
supplies including masks respirators and
all sorts of pharmaceuticals three point
five billion dollars to expand
assistance to child care providers and
child care the benefits to health care
workers first responders and others on
the frontlines of the crisis and these
are really brave incredible people have
to say and some of them are getting sick
and some of them are getting very sick
and some of them don't even recover
they're incredible people one billion
dollars for defense production Act
procurement we are as you know using the
Act but we use it only when necessary we
use it as leverage we generally don't
have to use it to accomplish what we
want to accomplish as of today FEMA has
shipped over 9 million n95 masks 20
million face masks 3.1 million face
shields nearly 6,000 ventilators 2.6
million gowns 14.6 million gloves and
we're sending more every day and we've
got tremendous amounts of equipment
coming in a lot
great companies are making equipment
right now the ventilators obviously they
take a little longer to make but we have
a lot of companies making them and we're
gonna be in great shape we took over an
empty shelf we took over a very depleted
place in a lot of ways as you know the
testing is going very very well and that
was obsolete and broken and we fixed it
and it's been going really good and I
think very importantly the the stockpile
we're really filling it up and we fill
it up rapidly but we get it out
sometimes we have it sent directly to
the states instead and again the state
has to be doing this kind of a thing
also we're sort of a we look we look
from behind a little bit and we look at
how are they doing and if they need help
we do it but it's their first
responsibility sometimes they just can't
get it but we load it up and we send it
out but if we can we have it sent
directly to the state
we want it to go directly to the point
where we want it
I can now announce something that I
think is incredible what they've done in
the Navy because the incredible naval
hospital ship the USNS comfort which is
incredible actually when you see it
inside will be underway to New York City
on Saturday so it's going to be leaving
on Saturday rather than three weeks from
now they did the maintenance quickly and
it was going to be there for quite a
while longer another three or four weeks
and it should be arriving I told the
governor 20 minutes ago Governor Cuomo
that the ship will be arriving at New
York Harbor on Monday I think I'm going
to go out and I'll kiss it goodbye I'll
go I'll go too
it's in Virginia as you know and I will
go and will be waving together because I
suspect the media will be following
Johnny gonna be following maybe you
never know
great ship it's a great vessels right so
if you want to go I'll see you there and
if you don't that's okay after being
fully loaded with medical supplies it's
gonna be it's loaded up to the top and
it's over at the door for naval base
that's where it departs it is expected
then to we're saving about three to four
weeks by the incredible work done by the
Navy and I actually look forward to
Saturday to see it go this ship will
arrive and I believe it's going to get a
little bit of a ceremony it's just
something very beautiful about its
incredible piece of work gonna be
landing at Pier 90 in Manhattan to
provide hospital surge capacity for the
New York metropolitan area so it's a
surge capacity they may use it for this
or they may have other people coming in
from hospitals unrelated to the virus
and then they'll use those hospitals on
land they'll use those hospital for the
virus but we'll see how they do it they
could you do it either way one way or
the other whichever one is best but it
could be because it's set up so well for
a regular Hospital that they may take
people out of hospitals and then use
those rooms for the virus the National
Institute of Health and the private
sector working closely with the FDA
continue to collaborate to discover and
test treatments and therapies that can
effectively reduce the duration and
symptoms of the virus and help very much
help people to recover and I'm firmly
committed to bringing these treatments
to market very quickly we have a we have
a lot of tests going on with regard to
different medicines and I hope I hope we
get lucky I hope we hit a lot of
talented scientists and doctors are
working on therapeutics a cure the
vaccines I think we're doing very well
well Tony may speak to that a little bit
later but I think we're doing very well
with regard to the vaccines I think
we're doing well with regard to a lot of
the things I just mentioned but we'll
have to see what happens well there know
fairly soon about a lot of
but it's very advanced and the vaccines
are very advanced prior to as you know a
fairly reasonably long test period of in
that case over a year every American
should be proud of the incredible spirit
our country has brought to this effort
it's been incredible citizens from all
walks of life have come together to turn
the tide in this battle we're witnessing
the extraordinary power of American
unity like a lot of people have never
seen even getting a vote you're talking
about trillions of dollars and you get a
vote of 96 to nothing we are waging war
on this virus using every financial
scientific medical pharmaceutical and
military resource to halt its spread and
protect our citizens I want to express
our tremendous thanks to the American
people for continuing to practice social
distancing like you people are
practicing right here it's I don't know
this room may never be the same
maintaining good hygiene and follow
government guidelines vice president
Pence lifts up that card every time and
it's not very complicated but hopefully
you can do that and your commitment will
make all the difference in the world and
that's one of the big ones will be for a
while stay home just relax stay home
making a lot of progress as we continue
to gather more information and
accelerate the testing where we're doing
record numbers of tests now far more
than any other country is done I told
you yesterday eight days here because
you heard so much about South Korea the
the media kept over them South Korea
South Korea we have a great relationship
with president moon and South Korea but
when I hear so much about South Korea so
in eight days in eight days we do more
testing than they did in eight weeks and
it's a very highly sophisticated test
we'll be able to deploy even more
data-driven and targeted approaches to
slow the ultimately you know it's a very
devastating thing but we will vanquish
this
virus and it's a lot of progress has
been made that's why earlier today I
said a letter to Americans governor's
describing how we will be using the data
to update existing guidance on social
distancing which will be developed in
close coordination with our nation's
public health officials and scientists
because of the sacrifices of our great
doctors and nurses and healthcare
professionals the brilliance of our
scientists and researchers and the
goodness and generosity of our people I
know that we will achieve victory and
quickly return to the path of
exceptional health safety and prosperity
for all of our citizens we have to get
back to work our people want to work
they want to go back they have to go
back and we're gonna be talking about
dates we're gonna be talking with a lot
of great professionals but this is a
country that was built on getting it
done and our people want to go back to
work I'm hearing I'm hearing it loud and
clear from everybody so we'll see what
what happens we're gonna have a lot more
information early next week and we'll be
reporting that back but I just want to
leave it with you we have to go back
this the United States of America they
don't want to sit around and wait and
they'll be practicing and by the way a
lot of people misinterpret when I say go
back they're going to be practicing as
much as you can social distancing and
washing your hands and not shaking hands
and all of the things that we talk about
so much but they have to go back to work
our country has to go back our country
is based on that and I think it's going
to happen pretty quickly I think it's
gonna happen pretty quickly a lot of
progress is made but we got to go back
to work
we may take sections of our country we
may take large sections of our country
that aren't so seriously affected and we
may do it that way but we've got to
start the process pretty soon so we'll
be talking to you a little bit more
about that next week and with that if
you have any questions you could ask and
then I'm
I have vice-president stay behind and
he's going to take questions and also
introduce some of the people you could
ask them some questions John please
numbers out 3.3 million yeah I think
it's not a surprise no never but still
staggering
well it's nobody's fault certainly not
in this country
nobody's fault we got very lucky when we
made a decision not to allow people in
from China at a very early date I say
that because some people don't want to
accept it but this was a great decision
made by our country or there's the
numbers that you're talking about we're
a big country they'd be far greater far
far bigger so when I heard the number I
mean I heard it could be six million it
could be seven million its 3.3 or 3.2
but it's a lot of jobs but I think we'll
come back we're strong the sooner we get
back to work you know every day that we
stay out it gets harder to bring it back
very quickly and our people don't want
to stay in so I I know those numbers
jump but I think you'll see a very fast
turnaround once we have a victory over
the the hidden enemy as I say it's a
hidden enemy sometimes a hidden enemy is
a lot tougher than somebody that stares
you in the face right so we'll see what
happens but I mean they're fully
expected numbers at least I mean at
least a place
why is that necessary well we have very
strong deployments on the southern
border as you know with Mexico and we
had some troops up in Canada but I'll
find out about that I guess it's equal
justice to a certain extent but in
Canada we have we do have troops along
the border you know we have a lot of
things coming in from Canada we have
trade some illegal trade that we don't
like we have very strong sanctions on
some we have very strong tariffs on
dumping steel and we don't like steel
coming through our border that's been
dumped in Canada so they can avoid the
tariff you and I charge a lot of tariffs
for the steel and it's been great for
our steel companies because now they can
really go you look at what's happened
with steel it's been pretty incredible
but we've taken in billions and billions
of dollars in tariffs on steel and much
of it comes in from China but they can
come through the Canadian border too so
we're always watching for that no I
think it's a tribute to our testing you
know number one you don't know what the
numbers are in China China it tells your
numbers and I'm speaking to President Xi
tonight I believe it will have a good
conversation I'm sure but you just don't
know you know what are the numbers but I
think it's a tribute to the testing
we're testing tremendous numbers of
people and every day the way the system
works and I want to thank especially
Roche has been fantastic great company
they've done a tremendous amount Deborah
was telling me before that they were
really they've really stepped up to the
plate and done great as have other of
the companies but it seems that they're
really doing it particularly well so you
know we'll see what happens there but
it's a tribute to the amount of testing
that we're doing we're doing tremendous
testing and I'm sure you're not able to
tell what China is testing we're not
testing I think that's a little hard
three point three jobless claims you
just suggested it could six to seven
million a lot of those work though I
didn't say that well you I didn't say
that I said some people were projecting
that would be six or seven and it's I
believe three point three millions of
Americans out of work some of them will
be losing their insurance what's your
plan to make sure it's there don't fall
over your owners you just mentioned that
they stay insured are you willing to
plus up the subsidies for some of the
exchanges under Obamacare expand
Medicaid what's being said oh well I
mean the things I just read to you are
being considered and other things are
being considered the people are going to
be getting big checks and it's not their
fault what happened to them is not their
fault so we're doing we're doing a lot
of different things on health insurance
we have meetings on it today
we're taking care of our people this is
not their fault what happened and we're
taking care we're starting off by
sending them very big checks I think for
a family of four it's about $3,000 and
we're taking care of our people were
taking care of our workers this was not
you know as I say this was not a
financial crisis this was a health
crisis of medical crisis we're going to
take care of our people as police
morning saying that 3% of all
restaurants in this country have
shuttered for good
it has through these and the projection
is that 11% more our Valley quotes in
the next 30 days so what do you say to a
restaurant owner who is looking at his
sheets and thinks he has to close well I
hate to I know the business very well I
understand the restaurant business is a
very delicate business it's a business
that that it's not easy you know I
always say in a restaurant business you
can serve 30 great meals to a person or
a family and they love it
one bad meal number 31 they never come
back again it's a very tough business
but they're great people that run
restaurants and I've heard 3% could be
lost and you could go as high as 10 or
11% but they'll all come back in one
form or another it might be a different
restaurant but it's gonna be a great
business for a lot of people and we're
making it easy for people to look what
we're doing what we're doing in terms of
loans what we're doing in terms of
salaries they'll all come back it may
not be the same restaurant may not be
the same ownership but they'll all be
back yes sir please
you see the defense production Act well
I talked about the defense production
act a lot and I've you know I've enacted
it I have it I can do it with a pen and
we have actually used it on two minor
occasions and then we could withdraw it
but for the most part the companies we
don't need it we say we need this and
they say don't bother we're gonna do it
I mean we we're dealing with for General
Motors 3m we're dealing with great
companies they want to do this they want
to do this they're doing things that
that frankly they don't need somebody to
walk over there with a with a hammer and
say do it they are getting it done would
that making tremendous amounts of
equipment tremendous amounts and when
this is over we're gonna be fully
stockpiled which they would have never
been except for a circumstance this was
this was something that nobody has ever
thought could happen to this country I'm
not even blaming look we inherited a
broken situation but I don't totally
blame the people that were before me in
this administration
nobody would have ever thought a thing
like this could have happened but the
production act defense production act is
a wonderful thing but I just haven't had
to use it they know it's activated they
know I can use it maybe that frightens
them a little bit you know it's got
tremendous power but I haven't had to
they want this really pay but the worry
because they offshore to places like
Panama in Liberia they might not qualify
Senator Paul II has said that they
should move back to the United States
before they get a check do you agree
should they pay US taxes to get the US
taxpayer relief so I'm a big fan of
Senator Hawley and I also like the idea
there were some senators that didn't
want to do anything like Carnival great
company but they're based in different
places I won't tell you why I could tell
you exactly where they're based but I
won't do that
but they're based in actually more than
one places you know ship to register two
different locations I do like the
concept of perhaps coming in and
registering here coming into the United
States it's you know it's very tough to
make a loan to a company when they're
based in a different country but with
that being said they have thousands and
thousands of people that work there and
maybe almost as importantly that work
onshore filling these ships with goods
and products and the cruise line
business is very important and I know
Carnival what a great job they do Micky
Arison and I would think that we could
stick with Senator Holly and maybe
really look at that very seriously look
it's a big business it's a great
business it's a it's a business that
employs tremendous of number of people
outside of the ship itself I mean you
look you look at these ports it's loaded
up with shops and and and people that
are involved with the ship so we're
gonna work very hard on the cruise line
business and we're gonna try and work
something out but I like the concept
yeah sir the Senate bill includes Abe is
directly tied to the airlines and since
before the pandemic Boeing was already
suffering from you know four losses of
737 airplanes do you think it's
appropriate to use this legislation to
sort of provide them with seventeen
billion dollars of a on top of you know
25 billion that they could qualify for
as a passenger airline and another 4
billion that they could qualify for
airline is that bad so the airline
business is a very tough business over
many years it's been very very tough
it's got everything it's got labor it's
got very strong powerful you know you
look at the cost of these airliners
everything is tough very highly
technological you look at how
complicated how complex
it's got unions it's got everything the
airline business generally speaking as
unions it's a very tough business always
been a very tough business with that
being said we have to keep our airlines
going and we're going to be using some
now maybe we'll take a piece of the
airline's for
or the country for a country where we
loan money and we take a piece of it's
all fully ready we're ready to go but if
we didn't do that would end up with no
Airlines and we can't do that the
airline business is very vital to our
country it's a tough business we have to
understand that so not I mean I could
tell you other businesses that are
different kinds of business they're very
good businesses but airlines have always
been very very tough please yeah I
didn't call you a cold just gentleman
thank you thanks a lot on Monday you did
you speak I'm with Bloomberg yeah
Michael good mr. president on Monday did
you speak with Chinese President gee
before you urged Americans to not blame
Asian Americans for the coronavirus we
notice that she's backed off their
language I know you're speaking with him
no I didn't I speaking to him tonight
it's scheduled to go tonight I'll have a
call with President Xi of China very
good relationship no I didn't like when
they came up and it wasn't him somebody
at a lower level mid-level we found out
pretty much but they made a statement
that our soldiers brought it into China
came from China and you know we just
signed a very big deal with China
they're paying us a lot of money in
tariffs and other things they never paid
us ten cents so China is taking
advantage of the United States until I
came here with sleepy Joe Biden and
Obama and Bush and everybody else I'm
not blaming them I'm blaming everybody
they were allowed to five hundred
billion dollars a year they were taken
out we had trade deficits that were so
large nobody's ever seen anything like
it and we've changed it look now we're
taking and billions of dollars and we
gave some to our farmers because China
you know they targeted our farmers and
our farmers are very happy and and our
farmers got through a very rough period
because of what I was able to do took
the money from China and gave it to the
farmers and we had plenty left over
after that now we're going into a Phase
two negotiation with China but we're
getting 25 percent
on two hundred and fifty billion dollars
and then we're getting a lot on money
after that so we've never had to deal
with China that China took advantage of
the United States and you know what I
don't blame China for that I blame the
people that were right here because they
should have never allowed it to happen
but the relationship with China has been
a very good one judge mr. president the
president she asked you to call never
asked me to comment somebody might have
spoken to somebody but nobody spoke to
me about it I think it was time though
because you know I talk about the
Chinese virus and and I mean it that's
what came from you know if you look at
Ebola if you look at all a Lyme right
Lyme Connecticut you look at all these
different horrible diseases they seem to
come with the name with the location and
this was the Chinese virus but I don't
have to say if they feel so strongly
about it we'll see but you know we have
we just made a great deal with China
great hopefully for both parties but we
made a deal with China and we're gonna
do another one I looks like they want to
do it very badly maybe they'll want to
wait like Iran they want to wait to see
whether or not Trump gets beaten in the
election because would they love to
negotiate with the Biden or somebody
else other than me they would love it
that's their best dream in the world so
many others so there are some that maybe
a you know waiting until after November
third the election day but I think we're
doing very well it would be sad if we
blew all of the advantages that we have
right now because we've made
unbelievable trade deals whether it's
Mexico Canada Japan South Korea China
and others we have we have changed the
whole thing around please today you said
a notification letter to the nation's
governors saying that you will soon come
out with new guidelines a fast social
distancing and other items do you have
any data yet to suggest which specific
areas of the country may have their
guidelines relaxed which areas of the
country may have
I think Deborah will talk to you about
that and Tony in a few minutes but I
think we'll start talking about that
because we have to open up we can't say
let's close people don't want to close
John I say it again and again the reason
I do because I want you to report it
eventually go ahead Steve yeah it's his
call I mean I'll talk to him whatever he
wants to I mean you know we'll have I
think a very fruitful call I have a good
call tonight at 9 o'clock please yes
we'll be talking about that yeah we'll
be talking about the virus Thank You mr.
president
just by the jobless claims numbers today
the market rallied again it's up over
4,000 points the last three days again
record
yeah the largest charge since 1931 do
you think that the economic uncertainty
has passed no not yet it hasn't passed
but it's come a long way I think they
think we're doing a really good job in
terms of running this whole situation
having to do with the device I think
they feel that I think they feel the
administration myself and the
administration are doing a good job with
people keeping very important to people
in form because it was a great fear and
a lot of good things are happening the
mortality rate is and in my opinion
you'll have to speak to Deborah Tony all
of the others but in my opinion it's way
way down and that takes a lot of fear
out you know it's one thing to have it
it's another thing to die you know when
I first got involved I was being told
numbers that were much much higher than
the number that seems to be and remember
that people that have it many people
have it I just spoke to two people they
had it they never went to a doctor they
had it absolutely had it but they never
went to a doctor they never went to
anything then you report it you have
thousands and hundreds of thousands of
cases like that so you have to add that
to the caseload also and the people that
actually die that percentages is a much
lower percentage than I ever thought
that's one of the reasons I say
look we're going to beat this and we're
going to get back to work yes please
administration today the DOJ announced
charges against nicolas maduro for drug
trafficking big does designate him it
okay it's also expected there
Venezuela's going to get here really
hard by the coronavirus does the
administration see this as a weak point
we don't look at a weak point there's a
serious problem for over a hundred and
fifty nations the virus I would say this
Maduro and Venezuela we're watching it
very closely we'll see what happens but
that is correct those charges were made
please we will give you the notification
we'll let you know a lot of these areas
have not done testing yet is it safe to
say that the current guideline will be
extended into next week will you will
you wait to change those guidelines and
until you have the I want those
guidelines to go even when we're open
and fully operational and frankly much
of the guidelines like shaking hands
maybe people aren't gonna be shaky and
hands anymore
you know Tony had mentioned to me Tony
foul chase the other day that I don't
think he was would be too upset with the
concept of not shaking hands he was
saying that the flu would cut down the
regular fluidly cut down by quite a bit
if we didn't do that if we didn't shake
hands you know the regular flu of which
you know you have a lot of deaths and a
lot of problems with that too so I think
a lot of a lot of great things are gonna
when we're open just so it's just a
failure when we're open as soon as we
open that doesn't mean you're gonna stop
with the guidelines you'll still try and
distance yourself maybe not to the same
extent because you have to lead a life
but I think the time is coming how about
one more question go ahead in the back
she throw heads Lynch I also have two
questions because I'm asking about
behalf before impress as well so one
domestic question one international
domestically you've just tweeted the
other day saying that it's very
important that we totally protect
asian-americans yes I did very important
to me but still really very important to
me they have to we have to protect our
Asian Americans it's very it's a very
important that was a very important
tweet to me because I didn't like things
that I was hearing please go ahead
what's what's what's the concrete
measure that you're taking to combat the
hate crimes of cancer well I don't know
all I know is this asian-americans are a
country doing fantastically well I'm
very close to them as you know and
they're doing fantastically well and I
think they appreciate the job we're
doing but I did want to put that
statement out the social media statement
because to me Asian Americans a great
part of our country thank you all very
much we'll see you soon thank you
well good afternoon everyone the White
House coronavirus task force met today
we continue to move out on president
Trump's directive to slow the spread
with mitigation to advance and expand
testing across the country and to work
on the critical supplies that our health
care workers in our nation needs today
the president convened the nation's
governor's all of those states and
territories and reiterated to them that
with FEMA in the lead
our approach is our response to the
coronavirus in this country is locally
executed health care workers local
public health officials it is state
managed and it is federally supported we
took the opportunity to thank all of the
governor's across the country our states
and territories for their incredible
leadership and the partnership they
forged with this administration we were
able to confirm that 10 major disaster
declarations have been issued most
recently to New Jersey North Carolina
Florida Texas and Illinois we spoke to
them about the importance of the
economic recovery legislation that will
come before the House of Representatives
we believe tomorrow midday and we're
grateful for their efforts in working
for that unanimous bipartisan vote in
the United States Senate last night in
addition to direct payments for American
families the average family of four will
receive a direct payment of some thirty
four hundred dollars they'll also
receive payroll report many of the small
businesses even those restaurants that
you just spoke about will now be able to
keep people on the payroll for a period
of months even if the restaurant or the
business is not open with the governor's
though we talked about the 150 billion
dollars in direct aid to the state's a
hundred billion dollars in direct
assistance to hospitals of course the
expansion of unemployment benefits to
make sure that our states have the
resources to meet the challenges that
were so evident in those unemployment
numbers this morning on the subject of
testing pleased to report the testing is
available in all 50 states and in
partnership with commercial labs across
America this morning we received word
that five hundred and fifty-two thousand
tests have been performed and completed
all across the United States we want to
thank the American Hospital Association
and hospitals across the country that
are just now beginning to report in a
fulsome way the results of those tests
and when the president signs the law
tomorrow will actually be required by
law but as dr. Burks and dr. pouchy have
explained many times at this podium it's
so important that any hospital or any
lab that's doing testing report back to
the CDC and FEMA so we have full
visibility to provide the president with
the very best counsel good news today on
testing Abbott Laboratories submitted to
the FDA today a request for approval of
a point-of-care test this would be the
kind of test where you could go to your
doctor you could get the tests done
there at your doctor and have the
results in no more than 15 minutes dr.
Steve Hahn will be here tomorrow to talk
about progress in evaluating Abbott
Laboratories point-of-care tests also
speaking of the FDA on the subject of
swabs the FDA did announce earlier this
week that testing symptomatic patients
by swabbing from the front of the nose
is perfectly appropriate and it's
already begun across the country it
allows for self collection and it also
relieves the burden on healthcare
protection it saves it saves personal
protective equipment from being expended
when people can administer a test
themselves and dr. Burks will speak
about the importance and the
availability of swabs with regard to
supplies you heard the president speak
about what we have already shipped out
from the National strategic stockpile
more than 9 million n95 mass for
healthcare workers 20 million surgical
masks 6,000 ventilators and millions of
gloves and gowns
face shields in addition to that we are
working with a number of suppliers to
manufacture ventilators even while we
work with state leaders to assess not
just what ventilators are available in
their state hospitals but what
ventilators are available in private
hospitals across their state and
governor's across the country are are
doing great work evaluating the full
supply of tens of thousands of
ventilators that are available let me
also say thank you to the American
Society of Anesthesiologists and dr.
Mary Peterson the American Society of
Anesthesiologists actually produced a
video tomorrow they will host a webinar
for healthcare workers to demonstrate
how the devices that anesthesiologists
use can be very easily converted into a
ventilator that's appropriate for a
patient's struggling with respiratory
ailment like the corona virus and we're
very grateful this actually adds tens of
thousands of devices to the supply and
we're all truly grateful to dr. Peterson
and the whole Association for their full
cooperation with five of ten counties in
the country being the top counties for
coronavirus being in the New York City
metropolitan area let us reiterate our
recommendation that that any resident of
the Greater New York City area who has
traveled elsewhere in the United States
please check your temperature mind your
health and self isolate for 14 days what
we don't want again with five of the top
ten counties for coronavirus being in
the Greater New York City area we don't
want anyone and no one would want to
inadvertently carry the corona virus to
a community or to a family member
inadvertently because they've come out
of that community so again as dr. Fauci
said recently if you come out of New
York over the last several weeks before
the mitigation measures are put into
effect in particular check your
temperature mind your health and self
isolate for 14 days
it is inspiring as I prepared to
introduce dr. Burks to talk about the
data that we're monitoring on a regular
basis and dr. pouchy talked about
mitigation let me conclude by saying how
inspiring it is to see the way America
and the American people are responding
to this moment we all were awakened this
morning with record unemployment numbers
not unexpected during the time of
national crisis that we are facing but
what you may not know is that while
there were some three million plus new
unemployment claims Walmart announced
they're hiring 150,000 new associates
through the end of May Amazon a few
weeks back announced they're hiring a
hundred thousand additional warehouse
employees to meet a growing demand at
Amazon for online purchases CVS health
is going to provide bonuses to their
employees working with patients and hire
50,000 workers and Pizza Hut I'm told is
planning to hire more than 30,000
permanent employees and that's just a
short summary of a list that totals
almost a half a million jobs that have
been announced by businesses around
America and it's not just been about
jobs it's been about generosity an
Heiser Bush is making a five million
dollar donation to the American Red
Cross to support first responders Ohio
hotels is offering doctors and nurses
and first responders free rooms at any
of their 300 hotels all across America
and the pharmaceutical company AB V is
actually donating 25 million dollars to
the International Medical Corps and to
feeding America American businesses are
stepping up to partner with us to meet
this moment but they're being incredibly
generous as well to all of those that
are stepping in in the lead in providing
health care services and of course to
those most in need we can do this
America but it'll take all of us as the
president often says we're all in this
together
but as millions of Americans do their
part with 15 days to slow the spread
putting into practice the president's
guidelines for combating the corona
virus and its spread we grow more
confident every day
this too shall pass with the cooperation
and generosity and prayers of the
American people I just know that we will
slow the spread we will protect our most
vulnerable and we will heal our land and
now for information on the latest on
data and what we're seeing dr. deborah
birx thank you mr. vice president so
just as a summary of where it looks
domestically I won't talk so much about
the global issues at this time we do
have 19 out of our 50 states to be
reminded that had early cases but have
persistently low level of cases and at
this point have less than 200 cases so
that's almost 40 percent of the country
with extraordinarily low numbers and
they are testing some of our governor's
have been very adamant about their need
for test kits we have gotten them test
kits when we had Abbott add about a week
ago to the test kits we've been able to
open up additional test kits for a [ __ ]
for states that want to do surveillance
and want to do contact tracing these 19
states are doing still active
containment there at 200 cases despite
the fact that they've been measuring
them over the last three to four weeks
still though 55 percent of all cases and
55 percent of all new cases continue out
of the New York New York metro area
that's the New Jersey part and New York
part in particular I haven't added in
Connecticut or other counties at this
point we are concerned about certain
counties that look like they're having a
more rapid increase when you look at
Wayne County in Michigan and you look at
Cook County in Chicago so we have
integrated all of our information to not
only look at where the cases are today
but how they're moving so we can alert
FEMA to where we think the next
potential hotspot is all of the counties
that I've mentioned the hotspots are in
urban areas or in the communities that
serve that urban area and I think that's
something very important to remember as
we move forward because of the
innovations within our private sector we
continue to have these new platforms
added for laboratory testing and these
become critical platforms for states
that have very low rates and very low
rates needed to test why is that
important some of these machines have
wells and plastic plates that in order
to be effective you have to put on about
almost 96 samples and others are made
for four samples or 24 samples at a time
so what's critical for us to be able to
do is to match the need to the county
and state and that's the role that we
can provide advice on because we get to
see across the whole country and where
those items are needed most and so this
is allowing us to adapt and adopt really
allocation of tests or recommendations
to state of what piece of equipment they
may need of the fifty five hundred fifty
thousand tests you can do the math but
we're still running somewhere about
fourteen percent overall that means 86
percent of the people with significant
symptoms because remember you had to
have a fever and symptoms to get tested
at this point
so still 86 percent are negative these
are really important facts for the
American people I'm sure many of you saw
the recent report out of the UK about
them adjusting completely their needs
this is really quite important if you
remember that was the report that said
there would be five hundred thousand
deaths in the UK and 2.2 million deaths
in the United States they've adjusted
that number in the UK to twenty thousand
so half a million to twenty thousand
we're looking into this in great detail
to understand that adjustment I'm going
to say something that's a little bit
complicated but I'm going to try to do
it in a way that we could all understand
it together in the model either you have
to have a large group of people who are
asymptomatic who've never presented for
any tests in order to have the kind of
numbers that were predicted to get to 60
million people infected or of six
million people infected you have to have
a large group of asymptomatic because in
no country
to date have we seen an attack rate over
one in a thousand so either we're only
measuring the tip of the iceberg of the
symptomatic cases and underneath it are
a large group of people so we're working
very hard to get that antibody test
because that's a good way to figure out
who are all these people under here and
do they exist or we have the
transmission completely wrong so these
are the things we're looking at because
the predictions of the models don't
match the reality on the ground in
either China South Korea or Italy we are
about five times the size of Italy so if
we were Italy and you did all those
divisions Italy should have close to
400,000 deaths they're not close to
achieving that so these are the kinds of
things we're trying to understand models
or models we're adapting now to the
rillette there's enough data now of the
real experience with the corona virus on
the ground to really make these
predictions much more sound so when
people start talking about 20% of a
population getting infected it's very
scary but we don't have data that
matches that based on the experience and
then finally the situation about
ventilators we were reassured and
meeting with our colleagues in New York
that there are still ICU beds remaining
and there's still significant over a
thousand or 2,000 ventilators that have
not been utilized yet please for the
reassurance of people around the world
to wake up this morning and look at
people talking about creating DNR
situations do not resuscitate situations
for patients there is no situation in
the United States right now that
warrants that kind of discussion you can
be thinking about it in a hospital
certainly many hospitals talk about this
on a daily basis but to say that to the
American people to make the implication
that when they need a hospital bed it's
not going to be there or when they need
that ventilator it's not going to be
there
we don't have an evidence
of that right now and it's our job
collectively to assure the American
people that it's our collective job to
make sure that doesn't happen right now
you can see the state these cases are
concentrated in highly urban areas there
are other parts of the states that have
lots of ventilators in other parts of
New York State that don't have any
infections right now so we can be
creative we can meet the need by being
responsive but there's no model right
now I mean no reality on the ground
where we can see that 60 to 70 percent
of Americans are going to get infected
in the next 8 to 12 weeks I just want to
be clear about that so we're adapting to
the reality on the ground we're looking
at the models of how they can inform but
we also are learning very clearly from
South Korea and from Italy and from
Spain just to final because I know many
of you will look up my numbers the only
people who are over really one in a
thousand cases are people that have very
small populations like Monaco and
Liechtenstein so you will see a
different number coming from when your
population is really tiny one case can
put you over one to a thousand or two to
a thousand thank you thank you mr. vice
president I'm gonna change the topic
just a little bit because there was a
questions that came up and I've been
asked about this and a couple of media
interactions regarding the interventions
that we're talking about and it's
important because it's about something
that I said yesterday about what we
would likely see whenever you put the
clamps down and shut things down you do
it for two reasons you do it to prevent
the further spread just be called
mitigation but you also do it to buy
yourself time to get better prepared for
it might be a rebound it may be a
rebound that we get things really under
control and then you pull back which
ultimately we're gonna have to do
everybody in the world is gonna have to
do that you're either gonna get a
rebound or it might cycle into the next
season so what are we gonna do to
prepare ourselves for that one of the
most important things is one that I
mentioned several times from this podium
that is to clarify a bit about the time
line for vaccines and would that have
any real impact on what we would call
the rebound or what we would call a
cycling in the season certainly for sure
a vaccine is not gonna help us now next
month the month after but as I mentioned
to you we went into a phase one trial
and I keep referring to one vaccine
there's more than one there's a couple
of handfuls of vaccines at different
stages of development but they're all
following the same course and the course
is your first go in to a phase one trial
to see if it's safe and you have very
few people forty-five people within a
certain age group all healthy
none at really any great risk of getting
infected the reason you do that because
you want to make sure that it's safe and
then the next thing you do and that
takes about three months easily maybe
more so that's gonna bring us into the
beginning of middle of the summit then
you go to a Phase two trial or what we
say to three which means we're gonna put
a lot of people in there now we hope
that there aren't a lot of people
getting infected but it is likely there
will be somewhere in the world where
that's going on so it's likely that we
will get what's called an efficacy
signal and we will know whether or not
it actually works if in fact it does we
hope to rush it to be able to have some
impact on recycling in the next season
and like I said that could be a year to
a year and a half I'm not changing any
of the dates that I mentioned but one of
the things that we are gonna do that you
need to understand that has been a
stumbling block for previous development
of vaccines and that is even before you
know something works at risk you have to
start producing it because once you know
it works you can't say great it works
now give me another six months to
produce it so we're working with a
variety of companies to take that risk
we didn't take it with Zika that's why
you know we have a nice Zika vaccine but
we don't have enough to do it because
there's no Zika around same with SARS so
that's one of the things we're really
gonna push on is to be able to have it
ready if in fact it works now the issue
of safety something that I want to
make sure the American public understand
it's not only safety when you inject
somebody and they get maybe an
idiosyncratic reaction they get a little
allergic reaction they get pain their
safety associated does the vaccine make
you worse and there are diseases in
which you vaccinate someone they get
infected with what you're trying to
protect them with and you actually
enhance the infection you can get a good
feel for that in animal models so that's
going to be interspersed at the same
time that we're testing we're gonna try
and make sure we don't have enhancement
so the worst possible thing you could do
is vaccinate somebody to prevent
infection and actually make them worse
next and finally with regard I'll get
you to your question finally with regard
to therapies I mean we keep getting
asked about therapies there's a whole
menu of therapies that are going into
clinical trial as I've told you all and
I'll repeat it again the best way to get
the best drug as quickly as possible is
to do a randomized controlled trial so
that you know is it safe and it's
effective if it's not effective get it
off the board and go to the next thing
if it is effective get it out to the
people that need it so you're gonna be
hearing over the next month or more
about different drugs that are gonna go
into these randomized controlled trials
and I feel confident knowing about what
this virus is and what we can do with it
that we will have some sort of therapy
that give at least a partial if not a
very good protection in in preventing
progression of disease and we'll be back
here talking about that a lot I'm sure
thank you are you saying that at some
point in the Phase two trials that if
you're seeing some form of efficacy that
you may try to convince a laboratory to
school
even before even before when I go into
phase 2 I want to find somebody that's
gonna make it well partially the federal
government I think in some respects to
de-risk it but also investments by the
companies a lot of companies are not shy
now about doing that usually when you do
that at risk John you got to get some
backup for them and we've done that
we've put hundreds of millions of
dollars into companies to try and make
vaccines I wouldn't hesitate to do that
for a moment now but there's no domestic
travel restrictions what's to prevent us
money from a high-risk County going to
lowers County don't you risk rating the
patchwork system allowing more cases of
the cracks and the viruses for another
area country I think this is a very
important concept and it's why we've
really worked on messaging to the
American people about these 15 days to
stop the spread because part of this
will be the need to have highly
responsible behavior between counties
and I think the American people can
understand that that they will
understand where the virus is because
we'll have the testing data and where it
isn't and make sure that they're taking
appropriate precautions as they move in
and out of spaces I think this will be
critical for our future as we work
together to really understand where the
virus is and where it isn't in real time
[Music]
exchange you last week said arose on
Monday that you talked about a serology
tests something promising coming out of
Singapore where are we Oscar ology tests
the president said very quickly and then
is that what you need to do some sort of
community surveys so you can get to some
of these X and Z's so you can figure
this all out so we're talking to CDC
right now they are extraordinary in
outbreaks and contact tracing so they
are going to be the work force behind
any new strategy that looks at counties
that need to completely move into
containment and surveillance and contact
Racing but part of what they're looking
at now is where are these antibody
assays to be clear there is antibody
assays available right now but they're
by Eliza and what we're trying to do is
not just do Eliza's because they can use
that now but to be able to have point of
care rapid Diagnostics like we have with
HIV where you just get a drop of blood
you put it on a little cassette and it
tells you if you're positive or negative
so that's what companies are working on
yes correct
that's the IgG to measure them remember
that's not going to be helpful in
diagnosis that's going to be helpful for
us to know how many asymptomatic cases
there are that or were asymptomatic
rates are because that seems to be the
big question here very question it is a
very big question and so we have people
the FDA is working on that around the
clock they do have applications that are
coming in we put out a call for
applications we I've been talking about
it from this podium if you have an IgG
assay rapid test not an Eliza I mean you
could do the Eliza today because the
SARS the original SARS antigens react
very well to the current covet 19
antibodies that people have but we're
really working on that both the so that
we could have therapeutics that could be
plasma derived so thank you yes we're
very much focused on that well you know
there are states and I just want a
really recognized state and local health
officials that behind all of this have
continued to test and have continued to
do surveillance so we do have states
that have been doing surveillance all
along who have been doing contact
tracing all along it never gets reported
because it's not you know it's not that
exciting that they've identified ten
cases but there are states doing that
and have been doing it throughout this
entire outbreak and that's why we have
some confidence that that testing has
been going on we have to expand expand
testing for surveillance but this is
that we talked about a little bit
yesterday the flu platform so the flu
pop forum is driven
and off of emergency rooms and hospitals
reporting flu-like illness to their
state and local governments and that
then will with trigger the individuals
to get tested so we have a platform that
states and local governments are
completely used to they're not used to
doing it this late in the season they'll
do it usually through the end of March
but flu usually tails off a lot by April
so we're asking them to continue the
activation of screening of screening for
flu-like illness now that doesn't get to
his question about where's the
asymptomatic sand how much of that
that's that helps us find cases and
contact trays on acute on systemic cases
so these are very early days of us
trying to what we're trying to do is to
utilize a laser focused approach rather
than a generic horizontal approach and I
think in the 21st century we should be
able to get to that why am i confident
that we can do that because we do that
in sub-saharan Africa right now for HIV
that's how we're stopping the epidemic
there so we've done it we've done it in
resource-limited settings so I do
believe we can transpose that approach
here to the United States and be able to
have we have granular data down to a GPS
coordinate of a site of a clinic and
hospital we think that same thing can be
done in the United States something like
that like if there is a high-risk County
and you know the restaurants are but in
a low-risk County wouldn't your fear be
that people that high-risk County go
over to the restaurant
these are dialogues that the federal
government has to have with state and
local governments because state and
local governments make those decisions
and that's what's been inspirational to
me of seeing how much the governor's
understand where they are in their
epidemic and what they will need to do
in the future this is what we're trying
to tailor it requires us to have very
clear data disaggregation
the county and state level but I think
you've been hearing from us these
outbreaks and clusters we've been able
to very well define to date the one that
was in King County the one that is now
in New York City the one in New Orleans
the one in Wayne County so and we can
see that spread throughout the region
and those closely related counties so
this is what we're talking about how to
do surveillance how to do contact
tracing and how to do each of these
items to make sure that you prevent that
spread well we have to get all of our
data together we owe it to the President
and we owe it to the President to be
able to make that decision so that's
what we're working on right now is
getting that granularity president sent
a letter to all the governor's today
indicating that as every American
recognizes that the importance of 15
days to slow the spread that we're
approaching day 15 and what the
president told the governor's that we're
gonna listen to the very best health
experts in the world we're going to
examine that data very carefully and
we'll be presenting this weekend the
president a range of recommendations and
an additional guidance for going forward
the president's made it clear that in
his words he wants to open the country
up but we're gonna do that responsibly
and as the president told the governor's
today we'll do that based on the data
unless there was a last-minute glitch we
should probably see phase three passed
the House tomorrow already there are
many members who were talking about the
need for a phase four do you see the
need for a phase four and if so what do
you think should be addressed in well
first let me just say again how how
grateful the President and I and I know
governors across the country are for the
extraordinary bipartisan work that's
been done on Capitol Hill not just in
the bill that will be taken up by the
House of Representatives tomorrow but in
legislation last week that extended
paid family leave free coronavirus
testing to every American made sure that
all the agencies at every level of the
federal government had the resources to
meet this moment it's it's really been a
very inspiring time but what the
president's made clear to our governor's
we're gonna do whatever it takes and
already we're hearing from some
governor's about the need for additional
resources and we will evaluate those
very carefully and I think the Secretary
of the Treasury has already indicated
and and congressional leadership has
already indicated willingness to remain
open to that the American people the
American people know we're all in this
together and the unity that you see on
Capitol Hill the unity that this
president has marshaled among governor's
all across this country in our states
and territories will continue to drive
forward and we're going to make sure the
people on the front lines are our health
care workers and the people that are
serving them make sure our state
governments make sure every agency of
the federal government have everything
we need to put the health of America
first we'll see you back here tomorrow